okay hello everyone we are doing a
design review about historical countries
for both language
um all right I'm supposed to point this
to a different place
oh wow look at this it's all changed
um where do I go
foreign
I haven't used this since it changed it
some okay so I need somebody to oh
how do I set this there's probably a
dollar variable isn't there
how do I set this guys
uh I think you need to write the only
current
and here yes yes
like that
that's right
okay all right and and I need somebody
to remind me at the end of this to
switch that back please okay
and so if I do something like this this
is going to work can we tell give me a
test case so I can tell where I am
give me a test thing that only works on
current please
um
who told me to do something on current
so
one of the queries in the historical
country not
oh I'm seeing it it's right here tell me
let's try running the first one all
right
okay okay does that prove it's the right
place yes okay great
okay
let's get into action here
so give us a big overview of what what
we're seeing here
um in the last meeting we discussed that
given that the historical entities like
historical countries
uh probably has associated with each
many shapes or polygons we needed a way
in order to distinguish the
different kinds of uses the users could
have of this polygons
in the case that a user needed a
specific
polion or or something like that
the right okay so so okay hold on we've
got
um
okay so we have geovariant and we have
various kinds of different
representations of the thing with this
entity maximum expansion and so on we're
going to look at these okay
then
could you either find a quiet place or
put yourself on mute thanks but
um
one of the things we need to decide is
which of the Geo Brands we're going to
do to use for your functions
what is geofunction
you know do you do your entities deal
with it okay there's not called
geofunction I I nothing stuck by called
geofunction okay
okay all right so hold on so the first
thing here is we have this idea
of given
a named historical country
which we which is defined by some kind
of region and space time
we have a variety of things that we can
ask about that region and space-time is
that correct
yes
okay and so
there are
now
some of those so this is describing a
differently sculpted region in
space-time
here
and I'm well actually this is a slice
this particular thing so you've got this
right now it's a projection right
yes you're right you're right
right it's a spatial projection so
geovariant as defining spatial
projections of the space-time volume
other things like a duration property
for example or duration function would
tell us things about the time Direction
am I making sense well sorry now I think
the Geo variant I mean this represents
the maximum extent sort of stretched out
as like a prism you know through through
time right as opposed to like the dated
polygon which also represents a sort of
4D object but one that that you know is
not just projected if you know what I
mean I thought this meant
you know is there a piece of territory
Roman control
um maximum expansion is a slice the the
one that I think you're referring is the
one called Geo Group right what I don't
mean is right it's it's
okay it's it it comes from a slice a
particular moment in time but the way to
think about it in terms of like the
geometry is that it's like you're taking
that slice and you're stretching it out
into like a prism that goes to infinite
path and infinite future yeah I get it
right so if you were to do dated of
Maximum expansion even if it was a
thousand years before the gallic Empire
existed you would still get its maximum
expansion region is that correct
yes
yes okay
so okay by the way I don't understand
why duration doesn't work it should
imagine you've got this thing stretched
out in space-time duration is simply the
time from the you know the the maximum
time from the place where there was a
beginning to an end
in that space-time blob does that make
sense
okay sorry and does it happen that we
have an object that exists
intermittently
um that's a good question
something that came and went
exactly because then duration is not
well defined
or at least it's not well what about
what about countries that were conquered
and then got back their independence
well those show up as different
historical countries right now
is that correct guys are you can you
confirm that
uh yes in most cases okay let me give
you an example let's take Austria yes
and World War II Austria disappeared but
then it came back again is that the same
Austria is that a different Austria a
different one okay fine and that's what
we've always followed so every so one of
our axiomatic principles is the there is
a a time you know there's a Time
constancy to anything that there is it
never happens what Jose said never
happens
right of having of it disappearing and
then coming back again as the same
entity
is that correct
we can presumably confirm this we should
look at the database and confirm that
right
we don't have anything that has multiple
start dates and end dates right I mean
that's that's the simple case it says r
or anybody yes
so I think for for our purposes that is
how we have we have been defining
historical countries that they don't
come into existence over and over again
okay it seems a little unobvious because
I can imagine you know conqueror X
wanders into some place takes over for
uh six months and then is expelled and
the country goes back to the way it was
before
am I making sense yes I think in general
there are a lot of entities like if you
look at the Historical country list
there's a lot of you know we looked at I
think France last time and there's like
you know 25 Francis because there's you
know French Kingdom from this period to
this period kind of thing
right but I mean I'm just thinking
practical history right there are
certainly plenty of cases where you know
before the French Revolution after the
French Revolution before I mean let's
take the well no I mean before
well that's that's when we're at school
is France it wasn't like there was a
conquering entity from outside right I I
just what I mean to say is that we have
a very low bar for making breaking
things up into two entities and so if it
was taken over for six months I think
you know already you know it's very
normal for that to be broken up into two
entities
although
we still want it to be the case that we
can say you know France forever so to
speak all the things that were knitted
together in France but we're presumably
coming to that later in this
conversation right I remember last time
lots of discussions of Poland Lithuania
and things like that when we got to that
question yes
and we don't have um uh kosher so we
won't we won't hear about Poland this
time
unfortunate
um yeah the thing is uh sorry you have
the the definition of Geo entities for
instance of military conflicts inside
the Roman Republic
military conflict I don't understand
that
um
it doesn't need to have the it could it
works with the string it's just um
okay
something
fine no problem
um
okay
uh yeah the thing is what should be
there the the answer to that query
using the variants we could
uh return different answers I I
understand that I understand the
question yes I'm still getting up to
speed on what we have here
um is it all possible for you to find a
quieter locations those are
um
I I would assume that that the Geo
entity would would use the full
space-time you know thing
I mean dated
something right yeah that it would that
it would basically if it's in the
space-time volume
then
it is that
no rather than
a prism or anything like this
so right
so the default that's the thing that
right now is called Geo Group is what
you're expecting
is that what it is uh wait no I thought
Geo Group was was sort of all it was
sort of uh every region that was ever
part of the Romans the Gaelic Empire or
whatever but I think the idea here would
be you know if if there was a battle
that happened in what was part of the
Roman Empire but wasn't at this
particular moment part of the Roman
Empire that would not be counted if that
makes sense uh it's okay
right
is it contained in the space-time volume
of the Roman Republic
right when the battle happened would it
have been said that it happened in the
Roman Republic
yeah now is that do we have any
representation of the space-time volume
can our geometry stuff represent that
anybody I think last time we someone
made a little demo thing of it it wasn't
totally trivial though
okay
I mean arguably it's a thing but it's
more of a larger scale system issue
of being able to represent a thing in
space-time
who made that demo what was it I'm sorry
it's been a while since I saw it I
remember seeing the demo but I don't
remember Francisco made it only he has
the code still
Francisco can you remind us what that
was
I I would look for protocols yeah
but can you remind us what the demo was
the demo was a a 3D graphic of
the two-dimensional region on the earth
as a function of time correct
right so I stuck at the slices of the
polygons
on top of each other sorted by thank you
had this in one of your notebooks from
an earlier
meeting okay fine but I remember that
this actually brings up one of the
broader issues of these these objects in
general which is that the interpolation
is the hard part
I remember that was the I think if I
remember right in the meeting we had
sort of a a basic stacked thing and then
later I think he made like a one with
more interpolation but it was a little
bit jankier
but that that's how it has to be right
but the problem is
right
the question is how does this temporal
how does the time interpolation work
because we've got
you know there right I think the answer
is I think it's got to be I don't think
we can do anything smarter than just
sort of a step function if you know what
I mean where it's just right there's no
interpolation it's like all those here
yep
I mean it's just like it's just like
list step plot
assumes a fixed value right so if in
we assume that if the territory expanded
for example in 200 BC
that in 199
on December 31st of
oh let me not do BC because
I'm going to do ad
um 199 A.D okay December 31st 199 A.D
the territory was it's smaller size and
then the data point we have is for 200
A.D and therefore we will assume that on
January 1st 200 A.D the territory jumped
to the new form but that it's it's a a
hold and then jump you know list step
plot type thing is that right
is that the best we can do
I mean it's a separate issue that might
be an interesting perhaps even
crowdsourced curation effort to try and
do better than that
so I see two issues here one is that
these things tend to change abruptly in
in battles or something like that so so
the the stepwise approach may not be so
bad and the second is that to do this
internally generally we need a mapping
from boundary points to boundary points
because there may be topological change
islands that appear suddenly things like
that
so it's quite difficult mathematically
to do General interpolation here
right yes
yeah which team which is why it seems
like the you know it's it's like
interpolation order zero that that you
know the piecewise way is the best way
to do it
yeah I agree
right
but I mean an interesting question is
which seems not absolutely undoable for
example with a crowd-sourced curation
approach to say What battle was it that
caused this proboscis of territory to
change
in other words here's a question here's
a question if we tried to align military
conflict battles with changes of
territory have we tried doing that what
will we find
uh it it is a project uh tying up its uh
change in historical uh country with um
with either military conflict or
historical event is a project that we
have uh to the Future Okay have we
looked at others or do we know if it's
doable
do we know if typical changes of
territory are associated with one of
those two things
um
yes
but the alignment could be I doubt that
we have enough historical events to to
say something useful about that military
conflict probably is a little the data
is a little more dense and we could see
more of a connection okay but also a lot
of I mean just historically right I mean
it depends on the era and region that
you're talking about but like if you're
looking at something you know the 30
years war or something like that the
territorial changes will be from some
treaty that sort of was precipitated by
military complex but it's not clear
whether you want to then say you know
right which which caused it the Battle
of whatever or the Treaty of whatever
fair enough but but at least if we know
the treaty was signed this day then we
know that's the time when everything
changes
oh you're trying to increase the
resolution of uh I'm trying to find out
weather
right I think right now I mean for
reference right now I think everything
is at the resolution of a year or like
pretty much everything is at a
resolution of a year
right there's nothing changes on January
1st right
in many countries the independence is
declared first and then the battles
happen right so
yes yes
um
right or there's also lots of sort of
right post-facto things of like such
territories conquered and then there is
a treaty that sort of uh confirmed the
conquests so did the borders move when
the treaty was signed or moved when when
control was seized I mean look in any in
any War I mean as we can see in Ukraine
for example territory is moving around
every day and it's not even clear you
know there are regions where it's not
clear who's in charge and it's
untrackable
so it seems like the only way
you know I don't even know in in you
know
for some fraction of you know fairly
modern history Wars are usually ended by
is it true I mean was it usually ended
by some kind of treaty which defines the
the motion of territory on a particular
day
is that a fair assessment
I don't know I think that's I think
that's you know that's been the goal of
the last few hundred years I mean like I
don't know the Korean War for example do
you know of that and I don't know I mean
I don't know I famously didn't end in a
treaty it was just a cease
it didn't end right yeah right I mean
yeah right okay so that that's an
example where
okay so so
like that one where that moves to be you
know
yeah yeah okay so I think it's something
like the Treaty of Versailles there'd be
endless Pages talking about you know
this territory goes with these people
this territory goes to these people and
so on right
but basically the point is what is the
thing that we're representing the
space-time region what is it
right so what it presumably is
what what is it I mean because you know
it certainly is not tracking every
Army's progress during some campaign
but so what is our definition of when it
changes
and it's obviously messy
but do we have an operational definition
go ahead
well I mean someone who actually works
in the should try and answer I was just
going to say I mean the problem is very
analogous to just you know it's like
asking where where country borders are
because they're contested borders and
the answer is that's kind of messy and
fuzzy and I'm not sure there's really
any
you know any good answer yeah
um
right well so then that's the best we're
going to have probably that it's that
you know there are things which are
uncontroversial where something was that
way for a hundred years and wasn't
controversial and everybody that was the
common course of business was that that
everybody decided that was something in
you know Spain or something like this
um and then there will be
sort of
uh disputed places where
ah I wish we had a way I mean like for
example you know obviously with
quantities we have this notion of a
round
we don't have any such similar thing for
maps
well anyway we have to do what we can do
we've got certain data maybe we can
improve that somewhat although we are
probably as we split those hairs we're
probably going to run into all kinds of
definitional problems
is that what do people think about that
I mean in other words if we try and
tighten this up
it's I mean I think last time we sort of
concluded that if I remember I we sort
of just concluded that basically there's
nothing you can do that's that precise
it's all going to be kind of approximate
and so you know this is fine yep okay
fair enough everybody needs to know that
coming in door
but it's going to be approximate and we
we should signal that in the
documentation
right
um
we should just make some statement you
can Alan you you I I would encourage you
to write yeah basic statement I'm just
cutting that down right
you know historical countries are
necessarily blah blah blah you can even
have a little micro essay
maybe we even should do some posts
somewhere that we can refer to an essay
about what some of the issues are
making it clear it's you know to make it
precise is hopeless
okay let's get let's get into what we
really want to talk about here okay so I
just want to get some scope of what
we're talking about so is it the case
that the main thing we're talking about
is
these various geovariants and what
should be the default for which Geo
variant should be the default for what
is that is that correct is that the
primary thing we're talking about or is
there something different
that's one of the things but probably
the main the main one right now
okay all right okay fine so our proposal
is to make the maximum expansion the the
default Geo variant accepting the cases
where you stated we'll get to that
um
which is a different case with you know
with
um
existing countries right now where the
where the default is the well the only
Poly on the last polygon but what what
we've seen is that when people uh ask
for historical countries they usually
get uh the first thing they diverse the
first the polygon they get is the
maximum expansion so that seems okay so
that's correct one point is maximum
expansions won't tile the Earth
they'll overlap
right we all understand that right
so you know but even even then I mean we
don't have um you know at one point
um all of our historical countries
didn't cover the Earth either so
in a different way I mean there were
there were little city-states and then
there was desert in between us well
there were a lot of you know empty
spaces for unexplored exactly but what
I'm saying is the maximum expansion is
going to overlap many times oh sure
maybe here's a question though so I mean
it seems like right if you just say you
know gallic Empire of polygon I agree
you know maximum expansion is the
obvious the obvious thing but I think if
someone does something like the the Geo
entity you know of Roman Empire comma
you know Battle of Adrian opal or
something are you saying that that you
think should also use maximum no I
should no I think we all agree that
should use the space-time region okay
fine fine
right when things uh when when you need
dated things that's a different story
but uh that's not dated that that's
overall dates
it's asking
well no because the Battle of Adrian
opal is dead I mean I think what maybe
what you're saying is that if you know
in that case the badger Battle of Aging
Opals is dated and so in their case you
want to use the SpaceTime diagram but if
I said is Mount Vesuvius in you know Geo
entity of of uh you know Roman Empire a
couple volcanoes or something then you'd
say that then you should use the maximum
extent but really it's like those are
equivalent because it's just that Mount
Vesuvius goes to the infinite past in
the infinite future you know in the sort
of space-time yes exactly diagram right
right so another is there or isn't there
but if it's a point in time if it's a
point in space time like a battle then
it either is in the region or it isn't
in the region in the space-time region
or it isn't in the space-time region but
you're right I mean to ask the question
you know was
um
was this piece of territory Sicily ever
in
this Empire whichever Empire this is the
Roman Empire or whatever
this piece of America Geo Group not not
even a maximum extent actually but the
Geo Group
what does geogroup mean
yeah that's another thing we wanted to
discuss I'm not sure if the name gear
group is appropriate one
maybe maybe we could use Union instead
group is is all of the all of the
different shapes together so it's the
you know if if Rome at one point
controlled this territory and in another
disjoint Point controlled some other
piece of territory the Geo Group would
include both
what's the difference in that a maximum
expansion what may have never controlled
both things at once the maximum
expansion is just the largest It Ever
Was is it the largest polling in a Time
series the other you can see it as a the
union of all the polygons
oh wait a minute then I'm not sure I
agree with myself about what one should
do
basically you're claiming that
the default polygon for the gallic
Empire is the point at which the gallic
empire was at its greatest success
uh-huh
yeah
the moment of Maximum expansion which is
very typical like if you go to Wikipedia
and you look up a map if you look up any
map of the Roman Empire they always say
no Roman Empire greatest extent and you
know it's it's like a particular moment
that that they all show
why don't we call it gracious extent
rather than maximum expansion
because the name usually uses maximum
expansion
sorry what uses maximum expansion the
name you usually see in in all these
places that refer to to the largest
polygon is maximum expansion all right
okay
okay so that is a point in time
that is wherever it was you know 322 BC
or something there was at the it was at
their height
right
Geo Group is incomprehensible as a name
for the thing that you I I agree that's
why I uh we were suggesting perhaps
Union would be a better name
um right now your group just gives you
all the polygons available and the
better that would be all perhaps yeah
but then we don't need all the polygons
available we need all the different
polygons available so that you know we
can work with that so maybe Union is a
okay maybe what we could say because the
point is geovariant is a thing that's
used for many purposes so
indeed this is a separate discussion
that we could have here which is we have
used the ovariant because the entity
might be interpreted in several ways
but we could discuss whether we need a
separate set of functions that are
capable of handling all these various
time computations
so at the moment we are trying to put it
inside the geographic
only functions you know via dated and
your volume but it's not good it's a
good decision okay so hold on whichever
I would say should be maximum historical
expansion or something
you see what I'm saying to make it clear
because it's historical countries and we
don't say historical polygon we just
call it polygon
no I I understand that but what I'm
saying is this is a geo variant which is
a shared wrapper with other things
the word maximal expansion mean other
than
over time
well okay my point here is
um
that we could then go historical Union
historical reason it doesn't even
necessarily his well
right so everybody here's a question
then what would Union mean
in a Geo variant other than over time
like it seems to me that the only time
when you're going to have a Geo variant
their first multiple polygons
you know where you're going to want the
maximal one or the union of all of them
or whatever is going to be over time
well I don't know about that you could
have all these islands or something
include the islands of don't
that's a different thing right yeah it
is it's all areas which is essentially
the Union One versus maybe you could say
maximal region or something yeah we have
two different geo-variants for that also
okay so what are the geovariants that we
have right now
and then Jose is making the point that
maybe we did a different space-time Geo
variant
from these geovariants well actually I
think I think the more useful thing
which I think maybe is what Jose was
saying would be to have actual functions
that because right now the point is if
you ask for geovariant you know or if
you ask for the um dated polygon
geovariant which is the time series
there's no way to take that time series
and turn it into the maximal extent or
turn it into the Union one without
writing that code yourself
I think the point would be that we could
have those functions
right right what yeah as I say you're
varying is just a sort of selector right
you select a certain polygon or list of
polygons uh for something so
um but if you want to do um operations
uh over dated things then you're
actually Computing some something uh
over that certain uh
right now
other than inclusion
which I think we can only do very Junior
versions of is this point within this
space-time region
by the way notice that all these end in
area
yeah that's that shouldn't be the case
but well I'm not sure it shouldn't be
the case I I think I would have said
with all the full map no it's no I don't
think so I I think this is good because
I think that that the problem is
geovariant might be used for something
completely different
you see what I'm saying like Santa for
instance
what is Center
I don't know it says
I think it represents the point in the
middle or something yeah that's right
yes oh
so I mean that
yeah but at the end
your Varian will be used to choose a
polygon or a point or whatever to work
with right yes
um
okay
sorry not just a polygon here we are
discussing whether to have the cylinder
in space-time
oh yeah yeah
except that most functions don't deal
with space time the only one that does
is Geo entities
maybe we should have separate functions
which I think well I wish that we had a
better way I mean this space-time look
you know we've got all of the stuff for
spatial statistics and so on
we don't seem to have a representative
from that team here which is a shame
um
in case she is needed why don't we ask
Russia to join us
okay
um
because
you know in spatial statistics they are
doing well let's wait for Gosha to show
up but I mean that's spatial regions and
they have ways to describe spatial
regions they don't have ways to describe
space-time regions to my knowledge
I just don't think we should build a big
piece of machinery for doing space time
okay let me ask you this question Jose
in the Astro World are we going to need
space-time regions there
um not now the next step in Astro is
curves orbits
but I haven't thought about regions
okay and we've also want that for geo
right we want we want curves yes the the
Geo trajectories yeah
Okay so we've got two levels of this
coming we've got you know we've had
points
we have static regions
now we're about to have lines through
time you know points Through Time World
lines and then we will have you know
eventually we're going to be at String
Theory so to speak or something or
debrain Theory or something like this
um you know we're going to have these
things sweeping through time but we're
some distance away from that right now
there's a fair assessment here yeah I
think so so I think what we've got to do
right now is things that do not pretend
that we're doing serious work with
space-time regions
therefore we're going to have to stuff
this into geovariants and things like
that
right
another another Point might be that I
think a lot of the operations will I
mean one if we get sort of efficient
like geopolygon operations then a lot of
these operations on space-time regions
will hopefully be relatively simple I
mean it'll be something like you do like
a I forget if it's a Time series fold
but you either get you get the values
out of the time series and compute the
union of all of them that gets you
basically the Geo Group region or if you
want the maximal extent you just say you
know take the time series get the values
and then say maximal buy area yeah right
stuff like that or Geo area
right but now okay but so
okay you're raising an important Point
here which is that we do not have a
property that gives us the time series
and we should have that so that was
dated polygon
is it oh yeah there it is
an incomprehensible Geo variants
yeah I know I don't know right that's
part of the discussion exactly yes we're
not sure about this geography and dated
polygon because you can use you can use
just state it
uh for that date at all and then you get
all the
time series of polygons okay let's
understand what are the Geo variants
we're talking and and then there's
another thing that uh if you use that uh
dated polygon then you'll get polygons
plus days which is a different output
from what you get from other kind of
geovariants where you only get polygons
yeah well apparently Cento will only
give us a single point right well but
it's at least accordingly but anyway
it's a shape but anyways
a geographic object anyway yes well but
I I would argue that there still has to
be some Geo variant because presumably
the point is that like date if you use
dated come at all
uh
right like basically what you what you'd
be saying is that that the default Geo
variant like okay sorry the default Geo
variant needs a name right presumably
the default one is the whole space time
object and and you can get these other
ones by using other geovariants well
some way of naming the default one
I don't think they're claiming that is
the default
because for many purposes it's not the
default I mean if you want to just say
Gala Kemper polygon
the effective default is this maximum
expansion Geo variant I think yes right
yes okay sure let's go through this
again for a second okay Point number one
what we're doing is not the ultimate
solution the ultimate solution is to
genuinely have you know space-time
regions and things like that
um hey I we have Gosha here
um in spatial statistics do you have a
representation of a geo-region and how
does that work and what we're trying to
understand what would be a conceivable
representation of this space-time region
in our system
do we have I mean we don't have space
time right so
um in a special statistics right now all
we do is spatial we don't have a
connection with time
um some Dimensions can the spatial
statistics be in so
theoretically in how many the geometry
supports in Buffy talking about the
Cartesian space but uh practically up to
three
because we're dealing with the the
realistic situation mostly and for the
the Geo we we used to consider things uh
you know kind of on the on a map in that
way so it's two-dimensional
okay and the region stuff is arbitrary
dimensional isn't it
the regions yes but the the the question
is you know what can you do on the on
the region so in theory you can specify
your data you know with uh with whatever
with arbitrary Dimension but then not
you know all the functionality can be uh
specified yet
um to deal with that fair enough okay
all right we're gonna have to scuff this
into gear variants for now
and so the only question is how to name
them and I think we should go with as
explicit names as we can get because I
think that will prevent you know so
we've got three things we have to name
am I correct so wait so so we're going
to have a different output for your
variance in data polygons
yes as we as we do here why why why
don't just use stated
that
possibly because it seems like they're
two different things right because data
tells you data tells you given a space
you know a space-time object what slice
or what region do you want right like
what slice or what section do you want
as opposed to the Geo variant which is
telling you which space-time object are
we even talking about
so the way I see it is that with dated
you have a you have a Time series and
then you choose uh and start an end date
and you get the uh the the values for a
property for that for that timeline
right within that section yeah with
index actually yes and otherwise with
geotherm for me it's again it's like
some sort of selector you'd select Which
polygon or polygons you're going to work
with
without taking on account data or
whatever
okay so yes okay so look I I kind of
agree with you so maybe data polygon
goes away and it becomes dated a block
on all
because we do have no garlic Empire okay
so what we're saying is galak Empire is
really the space-time thing
that we can say dated of gallic Empire
comma you know 450 A.D or something like
this right
and that that is then in a Geo thing you
know we might say Geo area of that we
might say Geo whatever it is geographics
of that and that would work that is a
that is a particular
time slice of the space-time region that
is the gallic Empire
do we agree
and then it is consistent with our use
of dated that this would be a Time
series
right
okay all right so then
the question is
if we say
sort of the naked Gaelic Empire polygon
then what we are saying is we default
that to be
um
we default that by we assume that to be
the geovariant of this with maximum
expansion
okay now we've got one more geovariance
and and to be clear so data is a
geovariant of that column maximum
expansion
is sort of the same thing as writing
dated of Gaelic Empire comma you know
and then whatever the date is for its
maximum expansion like those represent
the same objects that's correct right
right
and except that except that with dated
you'll get a polygon plus a date
I don't think you do except for data
comma all right I think I think
and with your very you only get the
polygon I don't think you get a date
with dated here do you
I mean it may be wrong but you don't get
it
well no here's maybe the question I
think um I think we may even talk about
this last time and this relates to the
thinking of data as a slice or a you
know whatever if you say Geo entities of
dated of Gaelic Empire comma
all
or comma you know 450
uh and then you ask for military
conflicts the question is is it going to
interpret that as
as the the polygon at 450 projected into
all time or is it going to interpret
that as just a slice you know I think
that it's the polygon projection at all
time if you say Geo entities of this
comma
battles or something
I think
if you wanted that for battles on that
particular date
I would have thought you would put that
dated thing somewhere else am I wrong
where would you put it though I think
yes if you put that with a military
conflict
yeah you should get
um all the military conflicts
in that particular
um
polygon I'm not sure if it well but does
this work then if you want the one okay
so you're defining with the dated thing
here you're defining this is the
territory that is a naked polygon which
is the polygon for the gallic empire in
450 A.D
end of story and so then you ask what
volcanoes are in it you know what
battles at all time including battles in
World War yes without intersecting the
the dates
to make the intersection as well well
that's this not actually
so I guess the question is I mean
because again I think we talked about
this last time the question is what does
dated do to a space-time
object right I mean the Gaelic Empire
entity we've said represents one of
these space-time objects so are we
saying that dated you know if you give
it a particular date it takes it finds
that date and IT projects into all time
what happens if you ask for a an
interval
right does it just take that interval
but then on either end it will project
it into all time or what
sorry in this level for what
like if you give it a data if you said
dated of Gaelic Empire comma you know
450 to 500.
where in this Geo entities thing
anywhere I mean the point is that data
should represent a consistent object no
matter what function you give it to
yes I understand so I I claim
but what does that do normally now does
that does that
you're thinking that's a space-time
chunk
right and if that's a space-time section
then dated comma 450 should be just a
slice
as opposed to a slice projected at all
time
for example if you request the polygon
for an interval we are returning a Time
series
but if you request only one date we
return only one
so this would then just return a Time
series
which represents the space-time section
well we're trying a very weird time
series this would return a Time series
of battles that occurred at any time
in the gallic Empire of 450 A.D and the
guy and then the gallic Empire 580. so
let's say the gallic Empire expanded and
that included the position of the Battle
of Waterloo in 500 but not in 450.
right for your entities we are not yet
sure what this should return right now I
think the load is returning with the
maximum expansion or am I no I know but
that's when we have dated there okay the
default should be in my opinion Geo
entities Returns the for all time
maximum expansion
in other words if I say Geo right right
which which is right now the Geo Group
or or a union that we suggested no it's
not no it's not
yes it is I mean I think it's like
no because I'm saying for all time
that's right we say military conflict
here
or what do we call it anyway military
conflict yes Why didn't it come up on
the autocomplete
was it missing in the Geo entities
autocomplete that's a project yeah we'll
check okay all right anyway so this here
I'm saying that what this should mean
for consistency
is
in the region that was the maximum
expansion of the gallic Empire what
military conflicts occurred in that
region at any time
yes wait no we said the opposite earlier
earlier we said that that the Geo
entities would check for military
conflicts that happened you know in the
borders of the Gaelic Empire when it
existed right you're right you're right
that's what we said for this case right
I I think I think it's useful to think
of it outside of geoentities because I
think we need to know what you know
what does the entity represent what is
the dated entity and what are the
geo-variant entities represent before we
try and think about the most useful
thing is for you know Geo entities
because Geo entities can have its own
kind of defaults and so on but
Sandra is asking a question here
given a Geo position what country does
it belong to
I mean for current countries that is
simply Geo what is it called is it your
nearest or is it what what is it do you
identify oh yeah okay right fine so
geo-identify country
uh and then geoposition
you know 50 60 or something
why didn't that work I identified thank
you
okay great so that works fine so now is
it a case that we can say do I identify
a historical country
okay what do we think that should do
well shouldn't we specify a date
Yeah by default that shouldn't be
anything to do is give a Time series
a Time series of entities yeah
uh as of right now I don't know why that
isn't working do you identify the office
of historical country and a position
now returns a list of all the historical
countries that have contained that
position and if you use a dated wrapper
with one of the domains it returns dated
objects
of
uh maybe try with the entity wrapper in
historical country
just like this
yes
that's weird
I mean this is a position in Europe
isn't it or am I getting the coordinates
the wrong way around
we try using here
just so you know that you're not getting
something in the ocean
yeah I understand but I can I can just
do I predict this is France
bye-bye
okay so it's a thing that should have a
historical country identification
um
so okay so there's a bug here but what
do we want it to do we want this to
return a Time series is that a true
statement or not or a list no no we want
I see what we want is a list
that and how would we guess and only if
it's dated we will get a list of dated
entities okay so what would how would we
say that we say gated comma rule where
would we put that
around this or what
is that what you mean
so yes
okay would it work if I put the data
around the geoposition
um it should
you have some examples for this in the
notebook yes
okay all right but let's let's go back
again to
all right
we're saying that this means this thing
here means space time
you know
space-time containment so to speak
whereas gallic Empire of polygon
defaults to a geovariant of Maximum
expansion is that correct
well so so presumably if I say this if I
say dated
of gallic Empire I mean this should this
would presumably just work I don't know
whether it works now 450 A.D polygon
does that work
uh
well no because they are the entities
the date is outside yeah
okay when did it exist
is that a crisis of the third Century
thing should I try like list 250 because
it doesn't have to be in a list as well
on the date because isn't that an
absolute time if you just give it an
integer no not dated
okay when did the freaking calic Empire
exist
try minus 50.
oh
okay could you try just just taking that
and saying start date
270
like it existed for 10 years or
something
yes it's during the intense the third
Century crisis
okay okay
what was the crisis of the third Century
do I not want to ask
now is the the Roman at the Roman
Republic Empire broke into several
pieces for like a few decades okay fine
all right so this worked basically now
if we say this comma
what happens if we say this comma 290
for example
oh for God's sake what should that have
worked
are you sure that that's not being
interpreted
yeah
[Music]
because otherwise that's that's the year
270 and the month of 280. I see
well that didn't work either but it
probably should have done right
hello is there a reason why that didn't
work
let's assume that's going to work okay
can we do that can we assume that's
going to work
okay so now
okay so the dated thing is at that
moment except for all in which case it's
the sequence or these things in which
case it's the sequence
and then
with saying
without dated
in things other than geoidance Geo
entities
if it is a property it's it's by default
the geovariant maximum expansion and
then the property
do we agree
well I I would prefer if the entity
represents always the same thing
so so I would say unless you add
something temporal it represents
something geographical
you have to obtain to get
dated stuff
but but then this wouldn't work
right so that would represent say all
the military conflicts in the combined I
don't think that's the right thing I
don't I I again the thing the Preamble
that I was giving is we're not going to
be able to get this perfect right now
because we don't have a representation
of these space-time regions yet so it's
going to be a little bit of a high so
wait yes so in this case you're going to
get all the military conflicts in the
maximum expansion of the garlic Empire
right
right now using the default as the
maximum expansion
then you use you have to use a your
variant Geo Group or you know wait a
minute maximum expansion does not have a
date associated with it it is simply a
region of the Earth
right project a bit in the space-time
interpretation it's just that region
projecting to all time right
yeah
so
I I think we we're not going to be able
to make it perfectly consistent right
now
without having your representation of
space-time regions and and I think in
the future that
yeah I mean arguably
instead of calling it historical country
in the future we might have some well
it's either a property of the I don't
know something that represents
space-time region but we're not going to
get there for several years
so therefore we need we need a solution
right now and I think the solution right
now that takes Geo entities
by default without dated to have a
different meaning for historical country
from what it means in the pure property
with polygon I mean we can just decide
for every property what is for every
property because for example if we say
Galaxy Empire start date it's absolutely
meaningless to say the gallic Empire is
supposed to be
you know maximum expansion gallic Empire
and then the start date that's
meaningless so really what we're saying
is this thing here is for that property
polygon
I mean one way to do it is to just
Define wait wait
I didn't understand what you said what
is a garlic Empire maximum expansion
started where no no I'm saying the
following thing okay if we say that that
gallic Empire by default is geo-variant
of gallic Empire comma maximum expansion
of that is meaningless
right but the the maximum the the
geovarian maximum expansion is only used
in the in the geofunction context not
only so I I know but but this is why
people are asking in the case of okay
fine but I'm saying if you say that okay
basically the point is in the definition
of polygon for a historical country it
is really the maximum expansion polygon
right so we don't have to say that yes
and although possibly we should just
have that property in and we should just
say by default polygon means maximum
expansion polygon but we should actually
introduce the property maximum expansion
polygon into a historical country data
okay let's imagine that we did that
we have that as a property then another
property is
um you know polygon Time series
okay we all know what that means
um
and then the other one is the you know
Union polygon basically
is that correct having different
properties will be much clearer
definitely at least from the point of
view but I believe that's what Geo
variant does right it chooses one or
more polynomials to work with
right but but the problem is that we
need them also in your variant because
uh how do you specify that when
searching like in video entities that's
why we introduce it also Center as a
possibility because what if we want the
your distance
okay so listen four Geographics we have
these properties okay which you can
explicitly specify Geographics would
default if you don't specify anything to
the maximum expansion polygon and
probably the polygon property on its own
because we use polygon for lots of
different things so we should support a
polygon property defaults to maximum
expansion polygon okay so one other
question about maximum expansion do we
do we have or have we ever had talked
about putting a property into historical
country that
we were saying up above the the maximum
expansion has no temporal information
but we should have a maximum effect
that's the one that's what I was looking
for yeah yeah we should how do you know
otherwise what you're really looking at
yep
and presumably we have that data okay so
let's let's go through so this I think
is a reasonable approach
now
now we have to ask the question
Okay so
with dated
we know what we're getting there
what happens if you say dated of garlic
Empire comma and then polygon property
of that
what are you sending here Francisco
so we we have that information of the
data as an annotation okay fine but I
think we should promote it then let's
also promote it as a maximum expansion
date because it's a useful thing to know
you know when was this it can be
promoted to the property right fine okay
but now
in a case like this when we have a dated
wrapper
I'm trying to understand can we ask for
the polygon property of this dated
wrapper yes we can
so the only issue is what does Polygon
mean
okay maybe we just shouldn't support
this polygon
okay polygon with no dated wrapper would
be the maximum expansion polygon if it
has a dated wrapper it's the polygon for
that date do we agree
yes no
circuit can you say that again if it has
a dated wrapper it is the polygon for
that date if it has no dated wrapper it
defaults to be the maximum expansion
polygon that is the polygon for the
maximum expansion date yes exactly
okay all right okay now
Geo Geo identify okay what does it do
so if you have a dated
um should the output updated always
include a date no besides the polygon no
no only when it's a range
why the different Behavior
because that's what we've done before
okay is it perfect no is it is it
consistent yes right I think the idea is
just that the default if you give data
at a specific date it gives you a
specific object if you give it a range
it gives you a Time series and the
default you know the default for Gaelic
Empire is interpreted as dated of Gaelic
Empire comma 270 or whatever the year
when it was biggest
right a possibility that we had explored
is that if the data is in the object
like a gallic Empire then we don't
return a data but if we have functions
in which the domain is wrapped in data
then we could return the objects dropped
in data
because it provides more information
with other things I don't know if that's
consistent but it is great
well I mean relate to that though
because you were just talking about
geo-identify so arguably with you right
because okay do you identify could do
two things the most consistent thing it
would do is if you just say
geo-identified historical country comma
here
uh is it would return all the historical
countries whose maximum extents included
that point although honestly that's kind
of a useless
computation yeah it should be the other
thing it could do because it could be
the union polygon in that case well
maybe but but we can't be that
inconsistent another thing it could do
related to I think what what someone was
saying earlier maybe was supposed to be
doing is it could it could interpret the
domain of of sort of historical
countries to be you know all of the
dated historical countries so you
imagine it's the set of dated of Gaelic
Empire comma 270 and dated of Gaelic
Empire comma 271 and so on and it would
return all of this sort of uh you know
dated of entity comma
interval objects
for all the countries that ever
contained that point if that makes sense
where does it think I am I think I'm in
Illinois
that's why it was that was before
Louisiana Purchase or something
what am I I'm totally confused
just explain this history to me for a
second I mean I think this is I'm sorry
this is so this
is now returning
sorry I Christopher I I spaced on what
you were saying could you is what you
were saying I was basically saying it
should do exactly that yes
ER that that it should assume I mean
that maybe we could sort of interpret uh
for the you know geo-identify could
interpret the domain of historical
countries
as sort of the domain of all of the
dated historical country objects if that
makes sense
because it just seems like otherwise the
default Behavior which would be finding
the maximum extents just seems kind of
useless yeah that's useless
I mean this is useful but a bit hard to
predict
when
but I guess that we can return things
that are not triggered right so so I
think this is the most useful answer in
the sense that it's telling you where
and when right so
so that's exactly what you will want to
know about historical countries
okay so what about Geo within Q
yeah we think here is a competition
between entities right not between
domains
Empire
comma
how come I got garlic Empire how come I
got that gallic Empire
okay Paris
okay Paris is defined for all time
what the heck
what the heck
well okay let's do give me another give
me another place
um
I don't know
I mean it's still we think you were
doing a date intersection maybe that's a
problem
Cesar
uh I'm not sure
um
no I think so I think that it's soon
it's doing a date intersection and
that's why you're not getting anything
um probably well I don't understand this
I mean this particular thing here if I
say
geolist plot for example of this
well I got my answer it did include
London I didn't know that
it's a lot bigger than I remember
learning was anyway who knows that's
presumably its maximum extent
correct that's right
um
boy that's a weird case look at this
thing here
you know what I think is going on there
I think that's a landfill
that filled in in other words this
Empire went to the ocean but the ocean
as it was then
I'm not sure that whoever drew that
polygon was thinking that that's right I
I think it's something yeah a matter of
granularity of a polygon yes
yeah it's more a lower resolution for
even for this story though once okay
okay in any case
I think we think you should work simply
okay so it's just about foreign
okay so do we think we've nailed what we
want here are we are we happy with what
we've got I think I think it's going to
have to be worked through and I think we
need to write down with some precision
what
okay so again Geo entities here will be
things in the space-time region of the
Roman Republic
if you want it to be within
the see for example in that case what
you have is the intersection of dates
also
yeah exactly that's what I'm saying the
space-time region yeah but whereas
should that be the case or should we
include another wrapper so that it does
that so that everything is going to do
that I think we should do this and I
think what we should do
is were you to say
okay so this is yet another case is
oh this is bizarre okay so I don't even
understand this I think this is wrong oh
no this this is oh for God's sake
yeah this is this is really confused so
uh somewhat weird query it shows every
country in the in 1500s
that shares territory or search borders
with the yeah okay I understand yes
right so here what I would say is if
this says Geo variant
of
maximum expansion
then that is a for all time polygon you
see what I'm saying as opposed to the I
mean maybe what we need to do is say
geovariant
of blah of thing comma
you know space time
region
maybe that's what we should do we should
have that and that is the effect that is
the default just as we say maximum
expansion polygon is the default if you
just say polygon for one of these
historical entities so similarly inside
Geo entities this Geo variant is the
default
and I don't really mind calling it
space-time region which is a bit Space
Age so to speak because it is a more
complicated concept and it's one that
eventually we will cover in a serious
way
comments from people so in other words
the default for geo entities is
space-time region the default for
geolist plot for example is maximum
expansion polygon
or maximum expansion so space
temperature will have a polygon plus a
date right
no it's it's it is it's no it's not
going to pull out the dates it's it's
going to just be which military
conflicts which are space-time points
right no no but but you're using here a
Geo variant
no I'm saying it's a geovariant that
includes dates but it doesn't return
in the case of Geo identify Geo entities
let's say Roman Empire what would you
no the question is does it return dated
of battle X comma date or does it just
return battle X
um wait wait wait wait but again
geotherm will go on to the historian
countries right say for example it's a
it's a selector again of the of a
different polio so what would you give
with your Varian
Roman Emperor space-time region I'm
saying this is geovariant
I always say military conflict here wait
wait wait wait yeah but on the one
before you're very the only do you have
anything in the space-time region what
will be your output there
a polygon
there's nothing output it just sits
there
doesn't do anything okay
right so in this case here it would
simply return a list of those military
conflicts which lie in the space-time
region
okay okay as opposed to the following
Maybe
dated of this comma all which would
return some kind of Time series
I don't know if that makes any sense
that may not make any sense so the
reason why they were they had the
objects like the ones below
dated entity and the date
but I think that should be controlled
from the domain not from the first
argument
you mean from the military conflict part
exactly so the the data that's in the
next output are there because the second
argument in that input has stated yeah
fair enough
okay how do we make progress on this
um
yeah go ahead
right this is wrong this is
wrong this should be a Time series
um
yes and while developing the
geo-distance function uh the argument
was made that Geo distance always
returns uh quantity
and then we thought of making another
function like geodesistance time series
that would return no I'm serious no
listen guys listen listen listen
we've got points in space we've got
points in space time we're about to have
curves World lines in space-time
we haven't got the full space-time
geometry that we need to represent all
the things we're dealing with therefore
we are going to have to hack it
you see what I'm saying
so there's no way we're introducing for
something like this some kind of you
know dated geo-distance not a chance
that's for the future
that's part of trajectories right in in
hose in Jose's orbit calculations we're
going to be able
one of our poses was having a
geo-variant dated polygon the names may
be confusing confusing but which gave
you the time series of all the polygons
right
who is watching this we we don't know
why this hung up but we're back okay go
ahead say that again okay so 100 is
above if you can you scroll all the way
up maybe yep
yeah and then you have uh there are
gents your very enrollment Republic
dated polygon
right and that will give you a time
series of of all the polygons no we we
just made new names for this right right
so so but what I'm saying is that we're
just changing the name dated polygon for
space and regions
no that's a that's a property we want to
add but that's not the name of a Geo
variant
I don't really like having a geovariant
that Returns the the time series I think
that should be a dated wrapper
the question is what will be the polygon
property of the ovarian space thank you
right because I was wondering that which
would be the time series because that's
the closest representation we have for
me
space-time reading right yeah
well it could be an error it could be it
could be a
foreign
I think it's fine to have two
representations of the same thing
right because maybe at some point we can
improve one of them and leave the other
as the time savings only right
yes
okay so so where are we where are we
leaving this I mean okay first point is
have we made useful progress here and do
you guys think you've got I mean you're
gonna have to go through all these cases
because we haven't gone through all the
cases here
uh adding properties yes okay and
keeping the Geo variance as well yes
maximum expansion Union Etc and then
we're going to no no we're renaming them
we're renaming them what were their
names well I just told you the names
right yeah but I thought those names
were yeah but those are the properties
okay so fine so the Geo variants
the corresponding geovariance would be
times here well I don't know geovariance
the corresponding properties would be
probably space-time region and maybe
we've got a better name for that
but yeah Time series
that might be a Geo variant name okay
okay okay the polygon that the union
case is
um
something like historical Union or
something
well Union is pretty clear
I don't think it's clear I don't think
it's obvious what that means across
you know whatever Union can you get of
polygons well many different possible
unions if there's if there's a we've got
to make it clear that it's a Time Union
it's a union Through Time
okay what about maximum expansion
combined expansion and evolving
expansion something
the term expansion I mean the the
existing Geo variants all use the word
area for that
yes but because this is going to be
about time dependence we could change to
something well right but maybe that
becomes maximum area yep
and then
this becomes
combined area
okay or unified area
I don't think unified I mean that's not
something
yeah yeah that's main too political yeah
yeah yeah yeah right right
um
and Time series
the only downside of area but maybe this
applies to the existing ones as well
that it sounds a bit like it's going to
return a number
yeah I don't think we worry about that
we've already got that for the existing
ones but at least at least this makes it
clear you're getting a single polygon
single polygon and that one we're
getting a Time series
that seems useful
okay
okay
but that's fine anyway so it's one shape
right
okay what else do we have to figure out
here
um
no I think we have enough to
to implement that and see where let's
try this right yeah I think so okay good
stuff great this is very nice to see
coming together thanks a lot hey um
practical thing for
Christopher let's go to the meeting that
was supposed to be uh
okay see you there thanks everybody see
you later thanks bye